[Musica]
buonasera e quando scritto felice in due
non non avevo programmato di di parlare
di un amore diverso ma semplicemente di
parlare di amore della storia che stiamo
vivendo in quel momento che vivo tuttora
e quest'amore nella sua diversità credo
che sia unico e la cosa che mi ha fatto
più piacere è la mia grande
soddisfazione è vedere tante persone che
si sono riconosciute nelle mie parole in
questa sera non parlerò ma canterò e
quello che ho da dire lo metto sempre
musica è una frase di questa canzone
dice l'amore non ha sesso basta essere
felici in due io credo molto in questo
spero vi possiate riconoscere anche voi
in queste parole felici in due
[Musica]
occhi che brillano quando tib
e per rumore il tuo cuore che passa
per di un uomo
mi chiamo e trovano il suo
solo
sembrava fragili
mani certa
insieme ai capi
[Musica]
ed una gran pulse
disegnano parole nuove
pedone
ora che nasce con lo spazio questo porta
dello stato
dare tutto
amore che mi
centro
perché
se poi ti guardo siamo in
a sinistra
mondo
marche
mi dai
qui per te
[Musica]
amore che mi stai accanto
mai avrei potuto di poterti dire vuoi
sposarmi
il linguaggio dell'amore universale
puoi fidarti
nel cuore non lo stesso basta
giu
andare
[Musica]
parecchie
se poi ti può
siamo
questo
amore che mi dai un senso e non segna
[Musica]
il mio
su
tiri davanti a te qui davanti a tenermi
qui davanti a bellissimi paci tutto
sembra chiaro aiuto gli ato
ancora non voglio svegliarmi questo
sogno che ha fatto il lungo e noi ci
dotiamo dentro come fede di
es'intrecciano e come rami d'alberi
tocchiamo il cielo con un dito
sento e mi sa che che brillano quando ti
te
[Musica]
[Applauso]
pareggio
ma in un senso
[Musica]
c'è di più
si aprì giu
amore
stai attento
non giova
[Applauso]
amore
[Musica]
[Applauso]
amore mio stammi a casa
[Musica]
grazie
la prossima canzone si intitola non ho
più lacrime ed è frutto di una
collaborazione per me molto importante
con fiorella mannoia che ha scritto
prodotto questo brano e il free ora ci
siamo conosciute nella mia esperienza di
xfactor e mi ha accompagnato nella
finale con un duetto e da lì è nata
insomma un'amicizia e una conoscenza non
pensavo che potesse trasformarsi in una
collaborazione e invece è nata non ho
più lacrime e sono veramente felici di
cantare la qui stasera
[Musica]
noi siamo stati due diamanti ora siamo
sogni infranti vento che non muove
niente
siamo stelle spende noi come una fiamma
sola bruciava ogni parola
ora siamo nel sole
no ce la farò
[Musica]
anche se tavola
c'è
non ho più lacrime
[Musica]
riguardo
buongiorno
[Musica]
per te
no
[Musica]
noi non mi ricordo il primo istante non
mi faccio più a domande perché non trovo
le risposte stupenda nascoste
parto mentre t anno
mani
le mie mani
un salto nel vuoto
guardini
ce la farò
[Musica]
non ho più lacrime
l'idea
no
fatemi
[Applauso]
venuto
[Musica]
non c'è
draghi
il casco
roma
e di molto
non ho più lacrime
[Musica]
non voglio la crisi
grazie grazie mille per me davvero un
onore essere qui stasera
grazie